as a child growing up in Nigeria books
sparked my elías imagination but films
films transported me to magical places
with flying cars to infinite space with
whole universes of walls to discover and
my journey of discovery has led me to
many places and possibilities all linked
with ideas and imagination a decade and
a half ago I moved from working in law
and technology in New York to financing
producing and distributing films in
Nairobi Lagos and Johannesburg I've been
privileged to see firsthand how in
Africa a film powerfully explores the
marvelous and the mundane how it conveys
infinite possibilities and fundamental
truths after futurist films like poems
II when Erica Hughes superb sci-fi flick
paint brilliant pictures of Africa's
future while Rangan on your knees I am
NOT a witch Aniki our motto shows via
show us and catalog are present these
filmmakers offer new and snapshots of
africa's imagined and lived reality in
contrast to some of the images of africa
that come from outside and the
perspectives that accompany all of these
images whether sympathetic or dismissive
shape or distort how people see Africa
and the truth is many people think
Africa is screwed up images play a big
part of the reason why many tropes about
Africa persist from pictures pictures of
famine in Ethiopia 30 years ago pictures
of the Biafran war half a century ago
but on a continent
where the average age is 17 these tragic
events seem almost prehistoric their
images are far removed from how people
in Africa's many countries see
themselves and their neighbors for them
these images do not represent their
reality so what is Africa's reality or
rather which of Africa's many realities
do we choose to focus on do we accept
Emmanuel macron imagination of Africa in
2017 as a place in which all women have
seven or eight children or do we instead
rely on the UN's account that only one
of Africa's 54 countries has a fertility
rate as high as 7 do we focus on the
fact that infant mortality and life
expectancy in Africa today is roughly
comparable to the u.s. 100 years ago or
do we focus on progress the fact that
Africa has caught infant mortality in
half in the last four decades and has
raised life expectancy by ten years
since the year 2000 these dueling
perspectives are all accurate well aside
from McCrone see is just wrong
but one version makes it easy to dismiss
Africa's hopeless while the other feels
hope that a billion people can continue
to make progress towards prosperity the
fact that Africans do not have the
luxury of turning their gaze elsewhere
the fact that we must make progress or
live with the consequence of failure are
the reasons we must continue to tell our
own stories and share our own images
with honesty and primarily to an african
audience because the image that matters
most is the image in Africa of Africa in
African imaginations now honestly
requires that we acknowledge that Africa
is behind the rest of the world and
needs to move swiftly to catch up but
thinking of a way forward I'd like us to
engage in a thought exercise what if we
could go
back a hundred years say to the US and
1917 what we could take with us all the
modern ideas innovation inventions that
we have today
what could we achieve with this
knowledge how richly could we improve
quality of life and living conditions
for people how widely could we spread
prosperity imagine if a hundred years
ago
the education system had all the
knowledge we have today including how
best to teach and doctors and scientists
knew all we do about public health
measures surgery techniques DNA
sequencing cancer research and treatment
if we had access then to modern
semiconductors computers mobile devices
the Internet just imagine if we did we
could take a quantum leap forward
couldn't we
well Africa can take that a leap of that
magnitude today
there's enough untapped innovation to
move Africa a century forward in living
conditions if the will and commitment is
there this is not just a possibility
it's an imperative for Africa's future a
future that will see Africa's population
double to two and a half billion people
in just three decades a future that will
see Africa have the world's largest
workforce just as the idea of work
itself is being radically reconsidered
now taking the leap forward isn't that
far-fetched there are tons of examples
that demonstrate the potential for
change in Africa just 20 years ago
Nigeria had fewer than half a million
working phone lines today it has a
hundred million mobile phone
subscriptions and this mobile miracle is
mirrored in every African country there
are over three quarters of a billion
mobile phones in use in Africa today and
this has spurred justified excitement
about leap frogging
about bringing the sharing economy
artificial intelligence autonomous
machines to Africa and this is
promising but we need to think about
sequencing forget putting the cart
before the horse you can't put the
self-driving car before the roads
there's a whole infrastructural and
logical layer to innovation that we take
for granted or we have to triage for
Africa because some of the biggest
infrastructure gaps are for things that
are so basic the Westerners really have
to think about them so let's explore
this imagine your internet access went
off for a day and when it came back it
only stayed on for three hours at a time
with random 15 hour outages how would
your life change now replace internet
access with electricity
think of your fridges your TV's your
microwaves just sitting idly for days
now extend this nightmare to government
offices to businesses to schools to
hospitals this or worse is the type of
access the hundreds of millions of
Africans have to electricity and to
water and to healthcare and to
sanitation and to education we must fix
this we must fix this because ensuring
widespread and affordable access to
decent infrastructure and services isn't
just low-hanging fruit it's fundamental
to achieve in the hundred year leap and
when we fix it we might find some
unexpected benefits one unexpected
benefit of the mobile miracle was that
it led to what is perhaps the greatest
cultural resurgence that Africa has seen
in a generation the rebirth of African
popular music for musicians like
p-square
bongo muffin and wizkid mobile phones
paved the path to local dominance and
global stardom and the impact isn't
limited just to music it extends to film
to beautiful engaging films like these
stills of poems II via and I am NOT a
witch show for while its external image
might be dated Africa continues to
evolve as those African film now every
now and again the rest of the wall
catches on
perhaps with Joe mangas hard-hitting
Viva Riva with Newton adraka is intense
Ezra or with up the romances circles for
etic Timbuktu with mobile Africans are
discovering more and more of these films
and what that means is that it really
matters less in Kinshasa locota know
what Kant thinks of African film or if
those opinions are informed or fair who
really cares what the New York Times
thinks what matters is that Africans are
validating African arts and ideas both
critically and commercially that they
are watching what they want and that
African filmmakers are connecting with
their core audiences and this is
important it's important because film
can illuminate and inspire film can
bring visions of the future to auskey in
the present films can serve as a
conveyor belt for hope and film can
change perspectives faster than we can
build roads in just over a decade
Nigeria's film industry Africa's largest
has taken the country's words and
languages into the vocabulary and
imaginations of millions in many other
African countries it has torn down
borders perhaps in the most effective
way since the Berlin conference sowed
linguistic and Geographic division
across Africa film does speak a
universal language and boy Nigerian film
speaks it loudly
making Africa's 100-year leap will
require that Africans summon the
creativity to generate ideas and find
the openness to accept and adapt ideas
from anywhere else in the world to solve
our pervasive problems with focus and
investment films can help drive that
change in Africa's people a change that
is necessary to make the hundred year
leap a change that will help create a
prosperous Africa an Africa that is
dramatically better than it is today
thank you Asante sana
[Applause]
[Music]